I started my live video starting a video
I tried to do this twice while I was up
at Supergirl and there was not enough
power enough juice to to get a gun
because I did it once before when I was
on Supergirl and I show people like how
the green screen worked and stuff all
right audience building hey folks it's
me fat Kip Smith and I am here today
with another guy come on in here
thin Jay Mewes hello and what we're
gonna do is unbox these cool ass culture
fly world's finest collection boxes
would they look like oh here let me turn
it around so I can do this put it in
your hands boy Wow
now show me the back boy it's ie and
show me sides boy what Sorokin okay so
the idea is it's the world's finest
collection by flipping and this is for
look Wayne industries so this is the bat
version they're doing for a month for a
year and this is the Batman one give me
the bottom of the box to flip it around
that company right there culture flying
I flew around again so this this this
company right here they make this and
these cats return runs Lucy's now why
cuz these cats are talking about doing a
Jay and Bob box so we were like well
we're going to see what the boxes are
like so they sent us these boxes so
we're gonna unbox this [ __ ] live did you
start yours I do not
Jason's also going to Facebook live this
and we're gonna hand our phones over to
Andrew kind of pushing the button
there's the Andrew Andrews gonna be
holding the camera so that we can unbox
this [ __ ] so Andrew I'm gonna hand you
around
there's that cult reply ladies Jim they
want to do Jim Bob box so we're gonna
see what's inside this they license they
did a license deal with Warner Brothers
with DC and they're doing the world's
finest collection for per year I don't
know what the charge would impose on the
phone but they charge how about this
I won't Facebook live because I have the
info there you go so the info is the box
which has your voices
it is currently shipping international
shipping available to select countries
what's another important thing people
want to know what a cost Oh so retail
value over under twelve except but that
was the membership each box here we go
each box cost forty eight ninety nine
plus shipping or you could buy the whole
year four boxes and save twenty bucks
you get more information at world's
finest collection calm culture fly makes
you go their Facebook page and stuff
like that it is the Facebook page is WF
of the collection anyway we're gonna
dive in man that's where you can get it
let's see what is about we've been asked
by a few people do want to do boxes with
you guys like Jay and Silent Bob boxes
and we've done a few at our store we
through saucepot we've done a few at the
Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash our
own this look somebody made a box just
for this [ __ ] and somebody thought of me
X X XL [ __ ] that's for the large
man someone thought of me and my penis
not really but you know what I'm saying
right let's do one leave your dick out
of this world yes we each have one
that's similar so I figure what we do is
we open and I'll take out an item you
take out an I don't take out the same
thing oh alright here we go ladies
gentlemen we're unboxing culture frauds
resents the world's finest collection
that's not a knife wait don't look at it
okay don't make me use this knife on me
open mine takes me a little longer
I believe in foreplay ladies and
gentlemen dives right it was all over to
clip me working your nipples
you know [ __ ] kissing their neck I'm
saying you look pretty all right nice
the way ladies gentlemen because we
never want to get here's the box let's
spin it to them you spend the TV yes you
know they can see so then we open it
yeah ready one two three
oh now look there's a little card that
tells us everything inside but let's not
look at that that's like looking at the
[ __ ] card that tells you what your
chocolates in the box the best way to do
it Biden each one leave having you move
I know it's when I want to open go you
take first well already check this out
Boosh oh my goodness it's raining out
it's raining out are you [ __ ] me oh
my gosh they need to get up on that
building could I see it's not gonna get
on me wet look at the handle dude it
looks like Batman's grappling ass it
shoots this is ingenious I have a joke
in the Jiang say Bob reboot that is kind
of like me knows I'm not gonna spoil you
but that is wicked man it's made to look
like Batman's [ __ ] guising gun let's
reenact the scene from Batman Returns
you're Vicki Belle I'm Batman
hold my waist get behind me I'm like how
much do you weigh where did you get
those wonderful toys yes
all right so the idea here though is how
bad if they didn't just grab and buy a
[ __ ] umbrella and [ __ ] like that they
made something from scratch they made it
from scratch [ __ ] up all right now I
get to go yeah you got that's nice I'm
saying they didn't like like all we
bought a hundred thousand of these from
the [ __ ] they made that no can we get
that in the box
I love it I love it all right I'm taking
this thing well I'm gonna take out mine
and leave it wrapped because that's what
Jason to get but now I'm taking out to
figure this is an exclusive
vinyl figure man you don't get it
anyplace but culture fly that's
unique one-of-a-kind world's finest
Batman figure shall I unbox it
yeah I'm box it I'll put mine up here
like that this is we're unboxing within
an unboxing section right here we go
there's a display all there is you could
say that for a display Batman rebirth
cover right there let's look at quality
of the merchandise oh my god that's nice
alright there's not a lot of
articulation but that's a good looking
figure and that cake looks babe you all
burn oh he's got himself a little
stained then you put him on and then you
stick him in there yeah he's got a
little diorama the intense concentration
good good this one this is my own poop
so that's badass
alright so that's back well you get to
pick what is this this my friends is a
oh I'm thirsty but what is it supposed
to be oh [ __ ] it's a it is a smoke
grenade travel mug smoke grenade it's
supposed to be a smoke grenade but it's
a travel mug for coffee drinks oh so you
can make it to protect you can pretend
it's a smoke grenade yeah thank you like
you take a sip and you're just like
drinking your coffee here at the office
nice [ __ ] blows I want to do
something else with my life why am I
here and then you take a drink and
you're like oh I'm not here but really
it's just a mug pretty cool that's much
this is what I like though taxes Wayne
industries yes the tag alone is worth
keeping he's got a little bat symbol
there of course as bad I know it's still
plugged so it's a cup so we all got a
drink Batman got a drink that made me
just coffee when he wakes up at 5:00
a.m. to fight - Joker alright next piece
[Music]
I love patches and there's two there's a
Wayne industry patch and there's a back
insignia that's the logo symbol right
there but that Wayne industries dope I
made it myself
there you go that's pretty sweet cool
exact story nice all right so I'm
there's a lot of good-looking stuff here
but I'm gonna go with this piece right
here oh I'm like oh what this is in my
wallet do you need help opening that
locked box Kadesh it's a free utility
tool
what do you mean saw saw saw saw look so
that's a little wingnut so you could put
like nuts in here go dude
can opener snap knife the cut stuff sure
I mean that's sharp enough to hurt
should open the [ __ ] my brother's like I
need a knife this would totally open the
box this is a box opener for unboxing
stuff but it does actually happen here
all the different uses for this look at
this it's a open-air knife head
screwdriver ruler can opener for
position wrench butterfly wrench saw
blade directional and killer on vacation
ancillary indication thank you to
position wrench keyring hole it's a
floor cleaner it's a dessert topping all
those things I don't have my wallet on
me but if I did I believe this is like
perfect to fit right in your wallet so
you can put it back in the case is it
made of metal oh yeah do it so you can't
bring it on planes
yeah no planes all that stuff I don't
bring on planes
well I put it in your luggage packet
underneath yeah don't carry in your
pocket that's cool
that's us me very useful very useful
vitamins
mine was fair okay I'm taking this Oh Oh
watch it so it's your Tim's there's a
sweet little tin this is not a toy
this is not a toy I have that tattooed
on my dick oh yeah all right culture fly
made it what's inside it Woody's be a
battery please be a bath yes June two
bags
Oh tall bats pushpins
Oh let me hang up some pictures that
Kevin broke me gave me or you can eat
corn with them first that's right
they're corn balls man
you could do either or my friends but
how cool is that
which one do you think it is meant to be
first I believe it is meant to the card
will tell that look squid says that is
look at this [ __ ] right here if
bat-arang pushpins pushpins it looks
like Lucius Fox sent this to you oh yeah
he was like oh he's like your
billionaire spelunking grab mr. Wayne
there you go I don't get any jobs doing
Morgan Freeman boy servers good you're
next okay I have whoa no the evidence
bag I have evidence to put away so what
it is first show on the back city of
Gotham police department so you like
what can it be
it's an evidence bag it's two faces coin
[ __ ] hook it up the top says all that
information then there it is two faces
it's solid ice real silver dollars and I
scratch you did it yourself look at you
I like it when people do things maybe
I'm an American I'm lazy
Oh comes into evidence back so you can
use the push pins to push it on your
wall hang the evidence bag its didactic
oh it's didactic yeah and look at this
well I'm good Harv you're bad Harvey
let's see one for two times the amount
of trouble yes I saw it actually like
it's a solid-fuel sue yeah feel that no
man it's a great conversation piece you
got that for your pocket or if you want
to leave it in the evidence bag again I
feel like that's pretty cool great 182
pounds Harvey Dent waves his wife was
named Grace or Gilbert depending if you
watch the cartoon or the gum
okay I'm pulling out the shirt because
that's obvious it was sitting there the
whole time I kept skipping it you know
you got a boss cool cool [ __ ] when you
like do the shirt last and this is a
cool last shirt come on man
I'm so obvious is like odors picture
Batman it's like Wayne industry shirt
right there
it's like Morgan Freeman wore that
Morgan Freeman probably does but yeah
where's that Lucius Lucius Fox isn't
that's a nice shirt and again you know
they make them for large fellas and they
all the sizes I like that you get the
choice you're wearing them where's the
bed Sam where are the steps and soft
it's common well you got the last thing
oh I think there's two though if I have
another piece you are missing a piece
but I think it might have came out with
your other items oh okay here we go we
have another another evidence bag
sweetness
what [ __ ] I didn't know I'm in this one
you check that one out all right this is
the Joker evidence cart and it's his
playing card yeah it's a thick one it's
nice it's solid thick you know so it
doesn't get ruined it doesn't it's a
special one with some blood on it does
explode or no but I'd be awesome if it
came apart and you can make and throw
them this is not a this is really cool
it is it's dope
it's the dark hard and it's got that
more piece looks a little bit like Jim
Lee Sun Joon Lee doesn't say but it's a
nice Batman picture you use your Batman
pushpins to hang this up on the Batman
pegboard account awesome yeah you get
the pushpins hang this and there's four
so you got one name - dang the poster
one hang that evidence bag of the
Joker's and the shirts are absorbent
let me tell you something man we started
this journey gone like do we want these
culture fly people to make a box for us
we're finishing this jersey going
through [ __ ] yes dude they literally
made an umbrella that looks like
Batman's
grabs a grappling gun look at that
that's and you're never gonna find that
in a store that's badass I always play
Batman grab
with my brother now I don't have to
pretend real things right there
shirts toys and though you have this
this is a cold piece because again if
you're confused and you like a man what
are these corn holders or pushpins
you got it all right there baby you're
the guy guy let's go into Denny's
because you're like if you're confused
all the pictures of the food or right oh
yes here's a cool box close fly we're in
maybe Jay and Bob box oh my god make it
for Christmas that'd be amazing and I
want the rest of these boxes but this
[ __ ] is into the Batman box I want to
see it Superman bucks won't see the
Wonder Woman box then who's dug for it
they're doing world's fun coach replies
doing a man go check out their website
or on Facebook
WUF collection yes world's finest
collection and there it is thanks for
hanging out with us while we unbox [ __ ]
more crap more crap that's right all
this stuff man one day we'll be gone
from this earth and people will be like
who were these strange people that drank
out of smoke grenades you should like
that we were proud geeks ladies
gentleman James saw Bob unboxing for you
right here
coach fly's world finest collection and
soon one day close you fly Jane saw Bob
collection yeah four times here could
you imagine that that's more times than
I get lazy ass there it is folks thanks
for hanging out on my Facebook lot we're
gonna take off and go play with our [ __ ]
yes